my name is andy knight i also go by
pandy for short in the python community
i am the automation panda and i'm a big
python fan just like y'all
so
have you ever seen those at tags on top
of python functions
maybe you've seen them on top of methods
and classes too
those are decorators one of python's
niftiest language features
decorators are essentially rappers
they wrap additional code around
existing definitions
when used right they clean up your code
better than oxiclean
let's learn how to use them today
so
best way to learn is by seeing actual
code here is a regular old hello world
function
when we run it
it prints hello world
nothing fancy here
now let's take that same function
and bam let's add a decorator
using this at sign
we just added a decorator named tracer
to this hello world function
so
what exactly is this decorator
tracer is just another function
but it's special because it takes in a
function as an argument
since tracer decorates hello world
the hello world function is passed into
tracer as an argument
wow
so what's inside tracer
this decorator has an inner function
named wrapper
can you even do that
with python yes you can
the wrapper function prints entering
calls the function originally passed
into the decorator and then prints
exiting
when tracer decorates hello world
that means hello world will be wrapped
by entering and exiting print statements
the decorator returns the new wrapper
function
anytime the decorated function is called
it will effectively be replaced by this
new wrapper function
so when we call hello world
the trace statements are now printed too
wow
that's amazing
that is how decorators work
decorators wrap functions around
functions
think about them like candy bars
decorator is like the foil wrapper and
the decorated function is like the
chocolate inside
but how is this even possible
that decorator code looks confusing
decorators are possible because in
python functions are objects
in fancy language we say functions are
first order values
since functions are just objects
we can pass them into other functions as
arguments
define new functions inside existing
functions
and return a function from a function
this is all part of a paradigm called
functional programming
python supports functional programming
because functions can be treated like
objects
and that is awesome
so
using functions as objects decorators
change how functions are called
decorators create an outer decorator
function
around an inner decorates head function
remember the outer function is like the
foil wrapper and the inner function is
like the chocolate
creating an outer function lets you add
new code around your inner function
some people call this type of code
advice
you can add advice before or after the
inner function
you could even skip the inner function
altogether
the best part is decorators can be
applied to any function
they make sharing code easy so you don't
repeat yourself you can follow the dry
principle
decorators are reminiscent of a paradigm
called aspect-oriented programming
in which code
can be cleverly inserted before and
after points of execution
that's neat
i recommend you check that out after
this talk
so remember decorators wrap functions
around functions like candy bars
hold on now
we have a problem in that python code
if the wrapper function effectively
replaces hello world
then what identity does hello world
report
unfortunately with the given code its
name is wrapper
and its help also returns wrapper
that's not right
never fear there's an easy solution to
this
the funk tools module provides a
decorator named wraps
put funktools.wraps on the wrapper
function and pass it in the inner
function object
and decorated functions once again show
the right identity
that's awesome
but wait there's another problem
how do decorators work with inputs and
outputs
what if we decorate a function with
parameters in its return value
if we try to use the current tracer
we get an error arguments broke it
but we can fix it
first add star args and star star kw
args to the wrapper functions parameters
and then pass them through to the inner
function
they will make sure all arguments go
through to the decorator
through the decorator into the decorated
function
then capture the inner function's return
value and return it from the wrapper
function
this makes sure return values also pass
through
if the inner function has no return
value then don't worry the decorator
will pass through a none value
thanks python
when we call the function with the
updated tracer decorator
we see tracing is now successful again
when we check the new return value
it's exactly what we expected
hello andy it works
wow that's
awesome but wait there's more
you can write a decorator to call a
function twice
start with the decorator template
and simply call the inner function twice
return the final value for continuity
bam
it works
but wait there's more
you can write a timer decorator
start with the template
call the inner function
and surround it with timestamps
using the time module
here we'll be printing the elapsed time
as the difference between start and end
bam
now you can time any function
but wait there's
more you can also add more than one
decorator to a function
this is called decorator nesting
order matters
decorators are executed in the order of
closeness to the inner function
so
in this case with these two decorators
call twice is applied first
and then timer is applied
if these decorators are reversed in
order
then each inner function call is timed
cool
but wait there's more
you can scrub and validate function
arguments
check out these two simple math
functions
add and subtract
nothing too fancy here
create a decorator named int inputs to
scrub and validate inputs as integers
add the wrapper function
and make sure it has positional
arguments
that's the star args
and the wrapper parameters
then
cast all r's as ins before passing them
into the inner function
here i've done that using a list
comprehension that's that
square brackets in a for a in args
if you're not familiar with list
comprehensions think of it as a really
cool way to do processing on lists or
collections without using a loop
definitely recommend looking that up
afterwards
now
when calling those math functions
all numbers are integers
using non-numeric inputs also raises a
value error
cool
but wait you guessed it there's even
more
you can create decorators with
parameters
here's a decorator that will repeat a
function five
times the repeat function is a little
different than the decorators we've seen
before
instead of taking the inner function
object it takes in the parameter
which in this case is the number of
times to repeat the inner function
inside there's a repeat decorator
function that has a parameter for the
inner function
the repeat function returns the repeat
decorator function
inside repeat decorator is the wrapper
function
it uses functools.wraps and passes
through all arguments that's star args
and star star kw args
repeat decorator returns wrapper
finally wrapper contains the logic for
calling the inner function multiple
times according to the repeat
decorator's parameter value
that's what the for loop does here
now hello world runs five times
i could change that to be four times
eight times 99 times
nifty
but wait there's even more
decorators can be used to save states
here's a decorator that will count the
number of times a function is called
count calls has the standard decorator
structure
outside the wrapper a count attribute is
initialized to zero
this attribute is added to the wrapper
function object itself
remember in python we can dynamically
add attributes to any object
inside the wrapper the count is
incremented before calling the inner
function
the count value will persist across
multiple calls because it's associated
with the wrapper function object itself
when we run this
initially the hello world count value is
zero because it hasn't been called yet
after making two calls the count value
goes up as expected and now the count
attribute returns two
awesome
but wait there's more
decorators can be used in classes as
well as for functions
here our timer decorator is applied to
this hello method
as long as parameters and return values
are set up correctly decorators can be
applied equally to functions and methods
decorators can even be applied directly
to classes this might blow your mind a
little bit
when a decorator is applied to a class
it wraps the constructor
note that it does not wrap each method
in the class
since decorators can wrap classes and
methods in addition to functions
it would technically be more correct to
say
that decorate decorators wrap callables
around callables instead of saying they
wrap functions around functions
interesting python is cool like that
so that's all great
but can decorators be tested
good code must arguably be testable code
well today's your lucky day because yes
you can test decorators
testing decorators can be a challenge
we should always try to test the code we
write but decorators can be tricky
here's some advice
first
separate tests from for decorator
functions from decorated functions
for decorator functions focus on
intended outcomes
try to focus on the wrapper
instead of the inner function
remember decorators can be applied to
any callable so cover the parts that
make decorators unique
decorated functions should have their
own separate unit tests
second
apply decorators to fake functions used
only for testing
these functions can be simple or they
can be mocked
that way unit tests won't have
dependencies on existing functions that
could
change tests will also be simpler
if they use slimmed down decorated
functions
third
make sure decorators have test coverage
for every possible way it could be used
cover decorator parameters
decorated function arguments and return
values
make sure the name and help are correct
check any side effects like saved state
try it on methods and classes as well as
functions
with decorators most failures happen due
to overlooked edge cases
let's look at a few short decorator
tests
we'll use the count calls decorator we
wrote earlier
there are two decorated functions to use
for testing here
the first one is a no operation function
named no up that does nothing
it has no parameters or returns
the second one is a function that takes
in one argument and returns it
both are very simple but they represent
two equivalence classes of decoratable
functions
the test cases will show
will verify outcomes
of using
the count calls decorator
for count calls that means tests will
focus on the count attribute added to
the decorator functions
because that's the side effect that's
the outcome
this first test case here verifies that
the initial count value for any function
is zero
the second test case calls a function
three times and verifies the count is
three
this third test case exercises the same
function
over to the left
to make sure arguments and return values
work correctly
it calls the
quote-unquote same function
asserts the return value
and asserts the count value
this collection of tests is by no means
complete
it simply shows how to start writing
tests for decorators
it also shows that you don't need to
overthink unit tests for decorators
simple is better than complex
and to be honest i wouldn't be the
automation panda if i didn't cover at
least a little bit of testing
so
up to this point we've covered how to
write your own decorators
however python has several decorators
available in the language and in various
modules that you can use
absolutely free
decorators like class method static
method and property
can apply to methods
in a class
frameworks like flask and pie test have
even more decorators
so let's take a closer look
let's start by comparing the class
method and static method decorators
we'll revisit the greeter class we saw
before
the class method decorator will turn any
method
into a class method instead of an
instance method
that means hello or that means this
hello method here can be called directly
from the class
instead of from an object of the class
this decorator will pass a reference to
the class or
it will pass a reference of the class
into the method
so the method has some context of the
class
excuse me
here the reference is named cls to
represent the class
and the method uses it to get the
class's name
the method can be called using
greeter.hello as shown on the right
wow
the static method decorator works almost
the same as the class method decorator
except that it does not pass a reference
to the class into the method
notice how its parameters are empty
methods are still called from the class
like here with greeter.goodbye
you could say that static method is just
a simpler version of class method
next let's take a look at the property
decorator
to show how to use it we'll create a
class called accumulator to keep account
of the tally
accumulator's init method initializes a
count attribute to zero
an add method
adds an amount to the count
so far nothing unusual
now let's add a property
this count method has the property
decorator on it
this means that count will be callable
as an attribute instead of a method
meaning that it won't need parentheses
it is effectively a getter
the calls to count in the init and add
methods will actually call this property
instead of a raw variable
inside the count property the method
returns an attribute named underscore
counts
the underscore means that this variable
should be treated as private
however this class hasn't set that
variable yet
that variable is set in the setter
method
setters are optional for properties
here the setter validates that the value
is set
to a non-negative value
if the value is good then it sets
underscore counts
however if the value is negative
then it raises a value error
underscore count is handled internally
while count is handled publicly as the
property
the getter and setter controls added by
the property decorator let you control
how the property is handled
in this case the setter protects the
property against bad values
so let's use this class
when an accumulator object is
constructed
its initial count is zero
after adding an amount to the object its
count goes up
its count can be directly set to
non-negative values
attempting to set the count directly to
a negative value raises an exception as
expected
protection like that is great
python packages also frequently contain
decorators
for example flask is a very popular web
micro framework that enables you to
write web apis with very little python
code
here's an example hello world flask app
taken directly from the flask docs
online
it imports the flask module
creates the app
and defines a single endpoint at the
root path that returns the string
hello world it says
flask's app.root decorator can turn any
function
into a web api endpoint
that is really awesome and it's one of
the reasons why flask is so popular and
so loved
it's so easy to make a web service
another popular python package with
decorators is pi test python's most
popular test framework
and it's probably also my personal
favorite python package
one of pi tests best features is the
ability to parameterize test functions
to run for multiple input combinations
test parameters empower data-driven
testing for a wider test coverage
to show how this works we'll use a
simple test for basic arithmetic called
test addition
it asserts that a plus b
equals c
the values for a b and c must come from
a list of tuples
for example as shown here
1 plus 2 equals 3
zero plus one equals one and so forth
the pi test mark parameterized decorator
connects the list of test values
to the test function
it runs the test once for each tuple in
the list
and it injects the tuple values into the
test case as function arguments
the test case would run four times
test parameters are a great way to rerun
test logic without repeating test code
so act now before it's too late
when should you use decorators in your
python code you may be wondering
my advice is to use decorators for
aspects
an aspect is a special cross-cutting
concern
there are things that happen in many
parts of the code and they frequently
require repetitive calls
think about something like logging
if you want to add logging statements to
different parts of the code then you
need to write multiple logging calls in
all those places
logging itself is one concern
but it cross-cuts the whole code base
one solution for logging could be to use
decorators
much like we saw earlier with the tracer
decorator
[Music]
good use cases for decorators include
things like logging
profiling
input validation retries and registries
these are all things that typically
require lots of extra calls inserted in
duplicative ways
ask yourself
this should the code wrap something else
if yes then you have a great candidate
for a decorator
however decorators aren't good for all
circumstances
you should avoid decorators for what we
would consider main behaviors
because those should probably be put
directly in the body of the decorated
function
avoid logic that's complicated or has
heavy conditionals too
because
simple is better than complex
you should also try to avoid completely
sidestepping the decorated function
that could confuse
people ask yourself this
is the code you want to write the
wrapper or the candy bar itself
it's the code you want to write the
wrapper
or the candy bar
itself wrappers make good decorators but
candy bars do not
i hope you found this infomercial about
decorators useful
if you want to learn more
check out this real python tutorial by
garet arnhele named primer on python
decorators
it covers everything i showed here and a
little bit more
so thank you so very much for listening
to me
again my name is andy knight or pandy
i'm the automation panda and a bonafide
pythonista
be sure to read my blog at
automationpanda.com
and follow me on twitter at
automationpanda
i'll be taking questions offline either
in zulu or you can also tweet at me at
automationpanda
so thanks so much stay safe out there
and enjoy the rest of pycon india 2020.